Alright, now that we have our landscape material working and set up and we have verified that
we're at a good point to move on to modifying it to include things like Landscape Grass.
Now for those of you who are not aware, Landscape Grass is a way to spawn hundreds
of different meshes in an area around the player and as the player moves throughout
the world these spawned meshes will kind of follow the player around so this gives the illusion that
the world is filled with hundreds if not thousands of actors but in fact all of these actors are just
spawned in a radial distance around the user. Now in order to do this we do need to do a few
things first we're gonna need to go to foliage and then we're gonna need to create
a landscape grass type so let's go ahead and do that now inside of the editor so I'm gonna hit
control space to bring up my content browser. I'm just gonna right click here and we're gonna
go up to our foliage and then landscape grass type so I'm gonna click on this and we're just
gonna call this landscape grass underscore zero zero and then we're gonna double click on it
to open it up. Now once it's opened we will need to add a grass variety to this by pressing
the add to array element and then once we've done that we will be able to select any type
of static mesh we want so let's go ahead and do that now so we're gonna pop back over here
so with this open again our grass varieties we just add an element to the array there we go
and then we come down here to our grass mesh and we're gonna add probably not that box
but let's look for I think we have some grass around here somewhere there we go I just saw
it I'm gonna add this well this Donnie Willow static mesh right here about also gonna take
this grass density and set this down to like a hundred because I don't want a crazy huge amount
of these and so we're gonna go ahead and hit save and I'm just gonna leave this at one for
now so we're gonna close that so the next thing that we need to do here is we're gonna go
into our material and inside of our material we're gonna add this new node called landscape
grass and the cool thing about this particular node is that we have total control over how the
landscape grass is actually applied to our landscape through our shader logic now for us
what we're actually going to be doing is we're going to be building this so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna take the slope and we're gonna multiply that by the grass amount and we're also
going to take a landscape layer blend now if you're not familiar landscape layer blends are
an option that we can use inside of the landscape tool to help us paint different
textures on our landscape but in our particular instance what we're gonna be doing is we're gonna
be using this landscape layer blend to help us mask out areas that should have this grass
bond and shouldn't have this grass bond and you might be thinking well why would we want
to do this well the reason that we would want to do this is so that we can remove grass from
underneath buildings or maybe in areas that it shouldn't be in and while the procedural
landscape grass is super useful and very very very performant it does have the one
side effect of not being editable so this gives us kind of the ability to edit that really
cool grass as well as control the placement so what we're gonna do first is we're gonna
pop back over to the editor here and we are gonna hit ctrl space to pull up our matte
landscape so we're gonna double click on this to open it up now the landscape grass
is a node that we'll have to add and it's not actually inside the main material
node here what we do is we right click in the event graph of the material editor
and we're gonna look for landscape and if we come down here you can see we have
this landscape grass output there it is alright and notice that it does have an input here so
what we're gonna do is first we're gonna select this and we're gonna hit the add element
I'm gonna hit that twice so I'm just going to delete one of these there we go and it's gonna
have we can give it a name and this name right here signifies the name that is going into
here and then we're gonna come here and just select our landscape grass so next what we're
gonna do is we're gonna set up our logic for this to follow so first off we're gonna
grab from here we're gonna grab our slope all right and then what we're gonna do is hold
down the one key and click and we're going to right click on this and go convert to parameter
I'm gonna call this grass amount and give it a default value of 1.0 then what we're
gonna do is we are going to multiply our slope times our grass amounts and what this is
going to do is it's going to make it so that we don't get any grass on our slope areas
and in the areas that are non sloped we can actually control the amount of grass here so
as we increase this number here we're gonna add more grass or more points to sample grass
to and as we decrease this number we're gonna remove the points so we're gonna remove the
amount of grass that can be sampled so let's go ahead and multiply these two together so we're
gonna do that by holding down the M key and clicking here and that's gonna add us our
multiply so there we go all right so next what we need to do is we're gonna hold down
the one key again and click and add a constant and then I'm just gonna control C and control
V to copy that and give it a default value of one so again hold down the one key and
left click to add a constant give it a value of zero and then duplicate that and give
it a value of one and these are gonna represent basically areas that don't have grass in areas
that do have grass so what we're gonna do for this is we're gonna left click and look
for our landscape and we want our landscape layer blend and we're going to have to give
this two layers so once it's added to the graph we're going to go ahead and press this add
elements twice and then we do need to give these some types of names in order to make it
easier for us to read so we're gonna call this first one remove grass and we're gonna
call the next one add grass and again we're gonna plug the zero into the remove grass
because when we don't have grass we don't want any information and we're gonna add
the one into the add grass because in areas where we do have grass we're going to want
that to have information last but not least we are going to need to multiply these
two nodes together to combine them so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna take this multiply
I'm gonna hit ctrl C ctrl V and then we're gonna plug this in like so and like this
one as well and once that's done we're finally gonna plug this in like so all right so let's
go ahead and apply and save and I'm gonna just close this down for now and right
now we're not actually going to be seeing anything happening and the reason for that
is what we have to do next for this to work is we need to actually go inside of our landscape
tool and then in the painting we need to add weight blended layers so we need to actually
add some layers or some masks to represent where the grass should be and where the grass
shouldn't be so let's go back over to the editor now we're gonna come up to our
selection we're gonna go down to landscape and then we're gonna come over to paint and
if we're not seeing anything in here that's okay we're gonna pop back out of this real
quick and just select our landscape I'm gonna hit ctrl space and we're just gonna take this
instance here and just reapply it sometimes we need to refresh our landscape in order
to get things to work here so oops and I did the wrong thing we're gonna grab that
instance and reapply that there we go all right that's what I wanted and now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna come back up to our landscape and there we go you
see I have my two layers there so we're just gonna hit this create layer info and it's
going to remove grass layer for now this is okay because we're just doing this as
a testing level and we're gonna go ahead and hit save there we go so we have our
two our add and our remove so we're right now we don't really have anything in there
so if I was to click on this add grass and paint there we go look at that I've added
some in that location and then if I was to up well hold down shift and do this
on the right layer there we go I will remove that grass there so if I want to
actually add grass to everything I can right click on this and go fill layer
and this is gonna add grass pretty much everywhere should be getting some
over here I'm not sure why it's not showing up over there what's showing up
over here so it looks like there just might be some weird type of interact
yes it's going as I I get over there so it might just be some weird
interaction there but the one thing to uh to take note of here is that we are
definitely able to remove grass because if I come over here to this
remove grass you can see I'm removing the grass like you would expect so I'm
not sure why it is not painting over here on these sides it should be no
idea why let's just come here and we're gonna rebuild our materials real
quick and let's see if that no it didn't have any effect interesting no it's not a
world partition level so it should be happening let's just try to do this
one more time here we're gonna go to our content and let's just replace oh
there we go so that's working weird the instance back in there okay so I
just had to reset apparently and now everything is working the way that it
should and the other thing to point out here is notice that while we do have a
majority of the surface here free there is a little bit of grass in there so
you know this is why it is useful to have this set up because we can then
just come in here and kind of start to remove some of these should we want
to get rid of them don't know why he's not removing them as I was talking
about this so might just have this because my brush is a little bit too
small oh there we go I think was my brush was a little bit too small so
there we go there it is removing everything off of the side of that
cliff there so all right fantastic so what we need to do next is get
everything set up so that we can also have different physical materials
on our landscapes